what's happening not much I'm excited to
be here I'm excited to have you here
your father speaks very highly of you
that's good
what does it like to have Jordan
Peterson as a dad is it weird you have
to check yourself constantly make sure
you're on on steady ground and is
anything ridiculous no not at all not at
all I didn't realize it was weird until
I went away to university and then kind
of so like just what was away for a
while and then when I came back to the
house especially because the house was
full of like paintings and masks and
statues and like 32 different paint
colors and they came back and was like
oh maybe he's a bit eccentric no he's
definitely eccentric we were talking off
air about what it was like to watch your
dad become famous and become famous and
in his 50s right like yeah I hope 54 55
that's when he became famous before that
relatively unknown respected professor
one issue with this one transgender bill
the the preferred pronouns bill and then
BOOM
off to the races yeah strange it was
yeah I was super weird especially how
the media was portraying him and how
what was actually happening at the
events wasn't what was being portrayed
in the media so that was weird to watch
and then people recognizing him on the
street is strange it's yes when you say
what what happened in real life was not
was what was being portrayed like what
was different um mostly what he was
saying so most of what he said is on
film anyway so you can go to youtube and
see what he's been saying like not
there's not like some secret that's
going around but what's been portrayed
has been so much more negative than what
he's actually said or they'll take like
sound bytes and just weave a story that
isn't quite true which I didn't read for
some reason I now it looks silly but for
some reason I just thought that what the
media was portraying was honest always
yeah yeah me too yeah yeah and it's not
well they're writers you know and what's
there's real issue today that issue I've
talked about this before but the issue
is clicks and it's not just about what's
the facts of this
it's about these publications are
struggling to stay alive and one of the
only ways that they can get people to
click on stories his salacious headlines
will make things really click baby and
that's what they focus on and they focus
on negative aspects that are going to
get people riled up they have to have an
angle and I've talked to people who are
writers who will write something and
then I'll talk to them and I'll say hey
man this is not what we talked about or
what happened and they said I'm gonna be
honest with you I didn't even write that
the head was completely written by the
editor so the editor came in changed it
all up change this switch that put some
dot dot dots out of things you know like
the so cut off sentences so that they
seemed more you know just more
controversial than they really are
because they didn't allow the
counterpoint of you know if sometimes
you say something and then you say or it
could be this well the or it could be
this part it's cut out you know they do
things like that just to stay alive
because I think when I mean really big
publications whether it's a New York
Times or with you know the Boston Globe
like big publications are struggling for
their life right now because people
don't wanna buy newspapers anymore and
you know and getting people to read
things online is very difficult and you
have to you have to do something
salacious you have to do something
that's enticing for them to click on it
yeah I guess but I wouldn't you say
that's just driving them down
yeah yeah would yeah they're [ __ ] it's
it's a bad place to be yeah and I think
it's you know it opens up the door for
alternative media but some of those
alternative media sources don't have
journalistic integrity either so then it
becomes a real issue
you know that's that that's a problem
with a lot of online news shows is like
they take a very obvious editorial spin
as well on the news and if you just read
or watch their show you would go oh well
it's this way because these guys are
saying it's this way but it might not be
that way there's no real objective
source is very hard to find a good
objective source I mean sometimes I
count on the New York Times but there's
been some things that I've read from the
New York Times I didn't know or not
a terrible article about dad Onan like
June or something yeah he didn't make it
any easier on himself by using that
forced monogamy our time now in forced
monogamy argument or term because I
don't even with when you understand it
as a psychological concept that it is a
culturally enforced idea I still don't
think that applies to in cells I don't I
just don't think you know I don't think
it makes any difference at all and he
and I discussed it on the podcast I'm
like you're not just because you say
it's a good idea and the culture agrees
that it's a good idea for people to be
monogamous I don't necessarily think
that that is gonna help these guys at
all I don't think we know what's gonna
help those guys yeah well obviously
they're all individuals in their
situations very but what we're talking
about for people like what the [ __ ] are
they talking about there was a quote in
the New York Times where this woman was
asking him what to do about these in
cells which are involuntary celibates
and one of them had driven a car into a
crowd of people and killed a bunch of
people because he was frustrated because
he couldn't find a mate mm-hmm and your
dad suggested that in culturally
enforced monogamy would be perhaps the
solution for that and then a bunch of
people went crazy saying that like women
he's saying that women should sacrifice
yourselves and [ __ ] these guys so they
don't drive cars into crowds yes yeah it
was the whole everybody made a mistake
yeah yeah for those guys I really don't
but no with that but that that was kind
of articles are like the editorial
articles and opinion articles it's
really it's a different thing than
reporting on the news right yeah I
thought I thought so honesty was always
a big thing in our house and was like
don't lie because if you lie eventually
the lie will surface and will be so much
bigger than the hell you get from
telling the truth mm-hmm so I kind of
just assumed that the media did that
yeah the world just worked like that
yeah no no I know that now yeah